notre vieil ami Eddie Murphy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
oui
on monte le chauffage là-bas il fait
bien chaud mais ici il fait un froid de
canard on se les gèle ça c'est très joli
merci à la Hollywood for and presse de
ma voix remis cette honneur insigne
ça fait 46 ans que je suis dans le show
business 46 ans
[Applaudissements]
donc ça fait longtemps que j'attendais
ça et je vous en remercie grandement et
je tiens à remercier Paige
tous mes enfants magnifiques pour leur
amour leur soutien leur inspiration
merci et je tiens à remercier
marklindsmann
ce qui est
prêteur
John Davis
une des bonnes personnes chez w.me
arnolder
grande personne de son époque et comme
je l'ai dit ça fait longtemps que je
fais ça donc je pourrais rester ici à
des blatérer déblatérer jusqu'à ce qu'on
joue du piano pour me faire sortir mais
je vais conclure pour dire à tous les
rêveurs les artistes en pleine ascension
il faut que vous sachiez qu'il y a un
plan très sûr que vous pouvez suivre
pour avoir le succès la prospérité la
longévité et la sérénité ça c'est un
plan et je l'ai suivi toute ma carrière
c'est simple il y a trois choses à faire
trois choses
payez vos impôts
name et ne parlez pas de la femme de
Will Smith
[Applaudissements]